So my name's
[Silence]
Alhamdulillah.
Continuing in.
Now we move on from the first
meaning of
which we mentioned
purification
in the books of
in the
in the terminology of the jurists of
Islam.
Purification
is used to refer to
purification of the place,
clothing
and body
from that which is considered to be
nudes, that which is considered to be
filthy.
And purification is also used to refer
to
and
which is generally referred to as
thank you.
So
if we were to just generally
you know casually
say what is one of the conditions of
salah we are to say woo is one of the
conditions of salah. This is casual
but in the specific
technical sense woo
is
obligatory for salah
for those who fit the criteria of having
to make wuboo. Correct.
Woo would not be good enough for a
person who needs to make for instance.
So for that person
making wudoo is not a condition of
salah. For that person in that in that
circumstance
is a condition of their salah or a
person for instance who does not have
access to water
and is not a condition of salah for
them. It is that is a condition of salah
for their set of circumstances in that
context. And this is why the scholars
do not list
or or
as being a condition of salah.
Rather they say a condition of salah is
[Silence]
they say
alleviating or removing this the state
of hadith. This is what they say is a
condition of salah.
So what is hadithat? Hadath that we need
to remove in order to make salah. Hadith
is a technical term which is a state of
impurity,
a state of religious impurity
that's that bars a person from making
salah,
handling the mus
and making around these
three things a person must have
must have lifted or must have removed
the state of hadith. They cannot be in a
state of hadith,
a a state of impurity
in order to make salah, in order to make
in order to handle the mus the mus in
Arabic. Right?
So these are three things that a person
who is a muith,
someone who is not in a state of purity,
this person cannot do. And these things
if if he were to do them, they would not
be accepted until he until he purified
himself.
Just the word janeba,
what is jeneba? Geneva is a state of
sexual impurity
that can only be removed by way of
bathing or by way of
in a certain set of circumstances.
So what do we understand from this these
these terms they're very important for
us.
We understand
that hadith
okay that state of impurity is actually
two types.
There's two types of hadith major
and minor.
Major
is a type of impurity that
nothing short of bathing will remove.
And minor
is a state that
woo will remove. So this is major hadith
minor hadithat major impurity minor
impurity. Remember the words
major impurity
minor impurity
and works for both
works for both. We know that this is a
state of religious spiritual
purity.
We don't know how it works exactly, but
we know that it has a real
effect, a real literal effect on a
person's soul and a person's standing
with Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala. Which is
why
it is the sunnah to make woo before
going to sleep.
Why? Why going to sleep specifically?
Because the soul is taken by Allah in a
partial way, in a temporary way when a
person is sleeping.
Therefore, it becomes befitting that a
person be in a state of
spiritual purity when they go through
that process of Allah subhanahu
wa'ta'ala
taking their soul in a partial way.
So we understand now major hadith
minor hadith
major impurity
minor impurity
demands what to remove it
right and then
takes either of their place in
circumstances.
This state of hadith is what our prophet
Sam
teaches us about in this opening
narration.
He says
[Silence]
he says
on the authority of Omar, this hadith is
in Muslim on the authority of Iban Omar
who narrates I heard the prophet
sallall.aii Wasam
say no salah will be ex accepted without
purification.
What is meant by
well it depends on the person's
circumstances.
But this that he is speaking about is a
reference to removing
the hadith the state of impurity. for
[Silence]
you inch.
forch.
[Silence]
for.
So he says that purification here is two
types.
purification with water and purification
with s it's not really accurate. It
is, you know, acceptable in a
casual sense, but in a technical
sense, it's not really adequate to say
that is using dust,
nor to sayum is the use of sand, nor to
sayum is the use of dirt, because
far more broad than that.
is the use of anything any particle
matter that
settles on top of the earth,
right? Anything that settles on top of
the earth naturally, whether that is
dust or sand or dirt or all of this a
person makes with.
So he says that
here in the hadith is two types.
Purification with water and purification
with we can say casually dust or
purification with that which is dry. We
could say that which is water or
purification with that which is dry. A
right? Notice how there's only two
choices here.
It's either water
or it is.
There's no third option.
It's not any liquid.
That will not
be valid for it can't just be liquid.
It has to be water.
So if a person didn't have access to
water but had access to Kool-Aid or had
access to you know orange juice or
had access to soda or had access to
motor oil whatever right these are all
types of liquids
there salah would never be valid with
this because it must be with water and
if there is no water then there is
right or if there's not enough water for
survival and salah then it becomes
[Silence]
I haven't seen you in a while.
quickly.
[Arabic recitation]
in that state of it's not obligatory.